people think like space is you know
these billionaires in their toys but
it's like you interact with space every
day whether you're using Google Maps GPS
or you know MRIs our whole world really
relies on all of this this data coming
from the space industry
[Music]
orbit Fab we're building gas stations in
space so we put up propellant Depots
into various orbits and we go to our
customers and refuel them so they can do
more in space
foreign
a cold email to a startup when I was in
the university and I got accepted to be
an internship for them and my co-founder
was the former CEO of that company and
ended up meeting him reconnecting with
him at a conference because he left the
day before I started and so we had a
bunch of different ideas together and he
invited me out to California and so that
night I booked a one-way flight came
home and told my parents I was moving
out in two weeks and we worked on
several different business ideas and
orbit Fab was really the one that stuck
both of us we really want to create
permanent jobs in space or you know
expand Humanity off this rock and the
only the only way you can really grow
any economy is by having cheap a cheap
energy source so on Earth it's oil and
gas before that we had coal and steam
engines and you could see that the
amount of goods and services that moved
around was very small and then we had
oil and gas a very cheap renewable
source that we could use and then our
economy exploded in the course of 100
years and so the thing that the space
industry lacks is this cheap energy
source that allows people and companies
to move goods and services and so that's
what we're providing
we launched the world's first Fuel Depot
last summer and that's currently in Leo
everything you know under between like
165 kilometers and then 2 000 kilometers
our goal is to really put out a bunch of
Depots and various orbits in Leo and Geo
and so Geo would be like where your Dish
TV your Sirius XM satellites are at is
this ring that's perfectly stable with
the rotation of the Earth and that's 36
000 kilometers we have fuel Depots which
are big simple tanks of fuel and then we
have our fuel shuttles which go from the
Depots to our customers and long term
you know just like we have highways on
Earth as we expand from to the moon and
to Mars and eventually asteroid and
Beyond you're going to be following the
Depots that we set on key orbits so just
like the highways layout with gas
stations so your cars can keep going
we'll be putting our Depots further and
further out as Humanity progresses into
our solar system
[Music]
we've fundraised through VC investment I
believe it's 25 million and then we have
about 25 30 million of government
funding that we've gotten through
contracts
I never really saw myself as an
entrepreneur but my parents always told
me you're a born entrepreneur I was like
no no like that's it's so difficult so
hard and then ended up you know finding
my way into it and now I absolutely love
it and I wouldn't change it for the
world you know just being able to like
manifest your visions and bring them
into reality and push the needle forward
for everyone has been really great
[Music]
I want my legacy to be you know helping
others achieve what they want to do and
spreading kindness you know I've got
three rules that I live by or three
values I live by really and it's treat
people the way you should be treated
bring more happiness into the world than
you take out and always do what's best
for future you in the future of humanity
the idea is completely changing the way
every country company operates in space
because no one has ever had to refuel a
satellite before and so it's showing
people that you know we can get over
this hurdle you know yes it's different
but the benefits that you that we're all
going to see by having this Arena this
energy source to move things around is
it's going to magnify everything and
we're going to unlock the potential that
the space industry really can bring to
people
[Music]